hello everybody and welcome to a brand
new video today we're going to be doing
another collaboration video with another
YouTuber today it's going to be uh
RuneScape exp lamp who messaged me a
couple weeks ago to do a video uh so
we're finally getting around to doing it
uh he's in the Skype call right now if
you want to say hello hey what's going
on sweet um so what we're going to be
doing is we're going to be going around
Room Escape to different places and
we're going to be flipping things based
on the places we go to uh that's going
to be decided by a random number or
wheel spin or whatever um so anything we
see whether a monster drop or any items
that are there uh we'll be able to flip
in Grand exchange for 1 hour and we're
going to start with 30 mil um but for
any extra rules I'll explain in a minute
all right let's go so there's 10 places
in total number one being mortan uh so
there' be the Slayer Tower and Barrow
Brothers some other things probably
number two is the desert uh kind of
think cight Queen but there's definitely
some other stuff there as well number
three is the Dual Arena uh the catch
here is that you can only merch stuff
you see people wearing um which should
be kind of fun number four is relica uh
so there's the Slayer cave you also take
the charter ships um number five is the
tly dungeon there's um the Obelisk
outside as well count um but tons of
monsters number six is um this place
obviously Z is the main attraction here
number seven the Trum stronghold which
includes uh ne's Cave probably the main
thing here uh number eight is ziris the
catch here is you can go anywhere in
zaris but you can also use fairy rings
but from the where you spawn from the
fairy ring you can't move so you can
only merge things that you can see from
the spawn which would be kind of
interesting uh number nine and 10 are
both Wilderness split between 25 plus
Wilderness and 25 minus okay so at
random.org open I'm just going to
generate two numbers for you guys uh so
we can pick the two places we're going
to go place number one is number eight
which is zarus and for the second place
we're going to get
number one uh which is uh canifis
perfect so we got our two uh places
let's get started all right three two
one timer started let's [__] let's
teleport away peace oh why am I running
why am I running the amount of stuff I
don't know where it is is going to be
pretty
apparent this is where it'll shine I
already got to look up some
stuff that's pretty ironic that a lamp
broke your computer oh [__] that's not
the right place I know it's funny as
[__] I didn't even think about that like
literally that never never connected
that I never getting food I hope I don't
get like [__] by something yeah I
brought I broughts just because I was
like I may take some damage and I don't
want that to be the reason I can't go
somewhere I sold so much my food I'm
using
salmon running around eating
shrimp Balling on a budget I just got a
really good one I just knocked off a
something I wanted to see we're good I
have one other big thing on my list
other than that I don't even know I
could literally back be back to the G in
like five to six minutes there's an
entire level of these oh please don't
[__] me oh I got salmon oh God run oh my
God no that is the worst and this is
kind of a spoiler but I can't go through
an agility shortcut I normally can right
now cuz my agility got reduced
that's [__]
[__] oh I'm I'm [__] up oh
God God that's
terrifying oh no something really messed
me up um some reduce my stats to like
nothing which you might feel a guess
what the [__] I'm talking
about all right wait my timer just ran
out what the hell are you doing I had to
see the last place
I all right I'm coming back I can't even
get through this stupid
Northern agility things so I'm running
all the way around
brck the hour clock has now started so
just [__]
go [__] yeah this is going this is going
to be something on time to go for the
the easiest merch in the [__] game
I don't know if you can guess what that
is but literally everyone does it zor
scales literally yeah all right there we
go we finally figured out an item I can
flip God Dam [__] good
[__] now how many of these are actually
traded a day oh [__] I was checked it
after I put the offer in these are
decent I
guess I'll settle for this
I did this in an hour challenge actually
I only got one so we'll go for two this
time oh my God that's terrible too what
is this those things used to have such
good margins yeah honestly some of the
items which like just common items you
can flip really easily are having some
pretty shitty
margins almost said allowed not that it
really matters almost anything could
have dropped
this yeah whatever you have at the end
we'll just make it a rule where you have
to inst them that could [__] me so
it's almost like an overwhelming amount
of items in some regards yeah cuz you
literally like you can do anything with
any of the drops and then you're like
[__] what do I want to do and it's just
like oh my God yeah I'm probably down
money cuz I already I lost like 60k just
checking something and yeah that hasn't
bought any of those what the [__] yeah I
don't even know if I'm in like positive
right now I spent like 50k checking
something right away and then have yet
to buy a single one of those why do I
even bother checking these really hope I
can find some other items okay we'll go
for
good try [__] it we'll check it we got a
good amount of money to play with I
guess
oh and then why is this item this item
has like 10 trade a day and I've sold
three of them already or this [__]
is none at all go for another three of
these
maybe oh my how did I [__] that
up oh I [__] it up really
badly yeah I like even common it
did a rune Scimitar flip like I I I
double checked it like three times and I
still have not sold like any of them oh
my God I just lost a okay I better buy
some of these
then yeah we pretty much have to buy at
least three or four of these or we just
lost [__]
70k we're like getting pretty close to
halfway wow I need to pick some quicker
items maybe I don't know what the [__]
going I'm feeling feeling pretty
confident
now I'm my
not well I guess we'll just drop this
down because it's not doing
anything oh my God I
didn't did I seriously
not get the Abyssal wow okay I should be
doing Abyssal whips oh my God it only
has a 1K margin on that what the [__]
this is kind of [__] up we' have yet
to buy any of this stuff um but I don't
know what to do at this point
can't do that no the the main items I
was going for just did not work I don't
even know if I'm going to be
positive instead of a giveaway you take
money yeah I I was thinking about that
like how's that going to
work all right we finally finished that
flip at least I've actually never seen
an item for red spiky vs I thought you
said Vans like the shoes I was like what
so confused I have to edit in like
explosions and like gunshots and [__] to
Len it
up you flip something for like a 3gp
profit air
horns didn't successfully buy one of
those I guess we'll pull that out could
do a coconut flip why
[Music]
not do what you got to
do thought about doing one hour of like
flipping fruit some [__] it's I'm really
bad I 's no expectations just make it
like totally obviously
fake whoa 500k margin on the
pineapple each do it can't you just buy
the full amount instead of just getting
a quarter of each that's my strategy all
along you have to give me NE I have to
give you negative
money oh man seems like I lost 15
mil we flip those quickly yeah
how much time's
left uh four minutes and 20 seconds yeah
I'm just going to spend the last four
minutes just looking at [__] I should
have
done I'm totally
[__] that would have been great that
one that would have been really nice to
do there were just so many options to
where I could have gone I just like kind
of flipped out and didn't really pick
any good
ones all right we're down to 50 seconds
yeah just going to sell everything off
here sounds good hitting the final
stretch so can I even inst sell these
okay let's see how much uh we have
left well yeah not not super
great okay timer's done goes the timer
all right hit me up with that trade
let's go I'm gonna bet you two M that I
lost
this all right how much do you think I
have I think you
made 620 okay all right I'm going to say
it sound like you came out with a loss
but yeah I'm going to say you lost like
30k something
respectable all right you
ready go three
two holy [__] I got [__] oh wait first
I'm going to try to guess what you had
all right guess what places I had what
are the options again let's see
um I bet you got zor
and I did
and 25 plus Wilderness now I got Zora
and Taverly dungeon so I went to
Cerberus and I was going to start
flipping like Eternal crystals or
smoldering stones but none of them were
buying so basically I made all my money
off of like I probably would have made
like three to 400k maybe five off of
like regular drops but I ended up
flipping like Serpentine Helms and
[__] uh tanzanite Fangs for like 100
to 150k each like damn it was insane
yeah I from what I can guess you got so
you had abber inspectors obviously so
that means you had one of two places you
could have cannabis
or but you need an agility shortcut
that's why I don't know which one well
the agility shortcut was just to get
into the grand exchange oh Jesus you
probably had I'm guessing you had kenome
stronghold then
did you have that one or no no no no you
had cannabis because I remember you
saying level so yeah cannabis and
[__] what what did you have just tell
me Zen zanis or zenar oh my God how did
that work yeah so I like I went to go to
so many different places and my stats
have been reduced to five so I couldn't
teleport anywhere after a
while so I had to use the glory thing
yeah I just got [__] I didn't have
that many options then I um flipping
like whips only had a 1K margin on it
then I tried all the D pieces which had
like a 50 60k margin but I just didn't
get any of them or you should have tried
to go all out on Abby daggers since yeah
I didn't even realize until later but um
yeah there's only like 20 traded a day
or something yeah I should have just all
in for that after just [__] but
whatever yeah either way uh since I got
[__] so hard I'm just going to give
you a flat amount so um you're going to
take this 2 mil from me and uh you can
give it to one of your subscribers um
however you want to do it really but um
yeah all right there you go instead of
you giving me 200k probably more
fair okay thanks for watching guys I
hope you enjoyed me getting screwed for
about an hour um but I had a lot of fun
doing it still um hopefully if we do
this again I will come out with a bit of
a better profit um but yeah again I
definitely go check out uh RuneScape
exp's Channel um to see his perspective
to see how actually got like 1.5 mil
which is pretty insane actually uh
beyond the fact that I got totally
screwed that's pretty impressive they
still got that much out of the 1 hour
but anyway hope you guys enjoyed and
I'll see you guys next time